The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN SHUN: Today,
we're going to talk
about multicore programming.
And as I was just informed
by Charles, it's 2018.
I had 2017 on the slide.
So first, congratulations
to all of you.
You turned in the
first project's data.
Here's a plot showing the tiers
that different groups reached
for the beta.
And this is in sorted order.
And we set the beta
cutoff to be tier 45.
The final cutoff is tier 48.
So the final cutoff we did
set a little bit aggressively,
but keep in mind that
you don't necessarily
have to get to the
final cutoff in order
to get an A on this project.
So we're going to talk about
multicore processing today.
That's going to be the
topic of the next project
after you finish
the first project.
So in a multicore processor,
we have a whole bunch
of cores that are all
placed on the same chip,
and they have access
to shared memory.
They usually also have some
sort of private cache, and then
a shared last level cache,
so L3, in this case.
And then they all have access
the same memory controller,
which goes out to main memory.
And then they also
have access to I/O.
But for a very long time, chips
only had a single core on them.
So why do we have multicore
processors nowadays?
Why did semiconductor
vendors start
producing chips that
had multiple processor
cores on them?
So the answer is
because of two things.
So first, there's
Moore's Law, which
says that we get more
transistors every year.
So the number of transistors
that you can fit on a chip
doubles approximately
every two years.
And secondly, there's the end
of scaling of clock frequency.
So for a very long
time, we could just
keep increasing the frequency
of the single core on the chip.
But at around 2004 to 2005,
that was no longer the case.
We couldn't scale the
clock frequency anymore.
So here's a plot showing both
the number of transistors
you could fit on
the chip over time,
as well as the clock frequency
of the processors over time.
And notice that the y-axis
is in log scale here.
And the blue line is
basically Moore's Law,
which says that the
number of transistors
you can fit on a chip doubles
approximately every two years.
And that's been growing
pretty steadily.
So this plot goes up to
2010, but in fact, it's
been growing even up
until the present.
And it will continue
to grow for a couple
more years before
Moore's Law ends.
However, if you look at
the clock frequency line,
you see that it
was growing quite
steadily until about the early
2000s, and then at that point,
it flattened out.
So at that point, we couldn't
increase the clock frequencies
anymore, and the clock
speed was bounded
at about four gigahertz.
So nowadays, if you
go buy a processor,
it's usually still bounded
by around 4 gigahertz.
It's usually a little bit
less than 4 gigahertz,
because it doesn't really make
sense to push it all the way.
But you might find
some processors
that are around 4
gigahertz nowadays.
So what happened at
around 2004 to 2005?
Does anyone know?
So Moore's Law
basically says that we
can fit more
transistors on a chip
because the transistors
become smaller.
And when the transistors
become smaller,
you can reduce
the voltage that's
needed to operate
the transistors.
And as a result, you can
increase the clock frequency
while maintaining the
same power density.
And that's what manufacturers
did until about 2004 to 2005.
They just kept increasing
the clock frequency
to take advantage
of Moore's law.
But it turns out that
once transistors become
small enough, and
the voltage used
to operate them
becomes small enough,
there's something
called leakage current.
So there's current
that leaks, and we're
unable to keep reducing the
voltage while still having
reliable switching.
And if you can't reduce
the voltage anymore,
then you can't increase
the clock frequency
if you want to keep
the same power density.
So here's a plot from
Intel back in 2004
when they first started
producing multicore processors.
And this is plotting the
power density versus time.
And again, the y-axis
is in log scale here.
So the green data points
are actual data points,
and the orange
ones are projected.
And they projected
what the power density
would be if we kept
increasing the clock
frequency at a trend of
about 25% to 30% per year,
which is what happened
up until around 2004.
And because we couldn't
reduce the voltage anymore,
the power density will go up.
And you can see
that eventually, it
reaches the power density
of a nuclear reactor, which
is pretty hot.
And then it reaches the power
density of a rocket nozzle,
and eventually you
get to the power
density of the sun's surface.
So if you have a chip
that has a power density
equal to the sun's surface--
well, you don't actually
really have a chip anymore.
So basically if you get
into this orange region,
you basically have a
fire, and you can't really
do anything interesting,
in terms of performance
engineering, at that point.
So to solve this problem,
semiconductor vendors
didn't increased the
clock frequency anymore,
but we still had
Moore's Law giving us
more and more
transistors every year.
So what they decided to do
with these extra transistors
was to put them
into multiple cores,
and then put multiple
cores on the same chip.
So we can see that,
starting at around 2004,
the number of cores per
chip becomes more than one.
And each generation
of Moore's Law
will potentially double
the number of cores
that you can fit on a
chip, because it's doubling
the number of transistors.
And we've seen this trend
up until about today.
And again, it's going
to continue for a couple
more years before
Moore's Law ends.
So that's why we have chips
with multiple cores today.
So today, we're going to
look at multicore processing.
So I first want to introduce
the abstract multicore
architecture.
So this is a very
simplified version,
but I can fit it on this
slide, and it's a good example
for illustration.
So here, we have a whole
bunch of processors.
They each have a
cache, so that's
indicated with the dollar sign.
And usually they have a
private cache as well as
a shared cache, so a shared last
level cache, like the L3 cache.
And then they're all
connected to the network.
And then, through
the network, they
can connect to the main memory.
They can all access
the same shared memory.
And then usually there's a
separate network for the I/O
as well, even though I've drawn
them as a single network here,
so they can access
the I/O interface.
And potentially, the
network will also
connect to other multiprocessors
on the same system.
And this abstract
multicore architecture
is known as a chip
multiprocessor, or CMP.
So that's the architecture
that we'll be looking at today.
So here's an outline
of today's lecture.
So first, I'm going to go
over some hardware challenges
with shared memory
multicore machines.
So we're going to look at
the cache coherence protocol.
And then after
looking at hardware,
we're going to look at
some software solutions
to write parallel programs
on these multicore machines
to take advantage
of the extra cores.
And we're going to look
at several concurrency
platforms listed here.
We're going to look at Pthreads.
This is basically
a low-level API
for accessing, or for running
your code in parallel.
And if you program on
Microsoft products,
the Win API threads
is pretty similar.
Then there's Intel
Threading Building Blocks,
which is a library
solution to concurrency.
And then there are two
linguistic solutions
that we'll be looking at--
OpenMP and Cilk Plus.
And Cilk Plus is actually
the concurrency platform
that we'll be using
for most of this class.
So let's look at
how caches work.
So let's say that we
have a value in memory
at some location,
and that value is--
let's say that
value is x equals 3.
If one processor
says, we want to load
x, what happens is
that processor reads
this value from a main memory,
brings it into its own cache,
and then it also reads
the value, loads it
into one of its registers.
And it keeps this
value in cache so
that if it wants to access this
value again in the near future,
it doesn't have to go all
the way out to main memory.
It can just look at
the value in its cache.
Now, what happens if another
processor wants to load x?
Well, it just does
the same thing.
It reads the value
from main memory,
brings it into its cache,
and then also loads it
into one of the registers.
And then same thing
with another processor.
It turns out that
you don't actually
always have to go out to
main memory to get the value.
If the value resides in one of
the other processor's caches,
you can also get the value
through the other processor's
cache.
And sometimes that's cheaper
than going all the way out
to main memory.
So the second processor
now loads x again.
And it's in cache,
so it doesn't have
to go to main memory or
anybody else's cache.
So what happens now
if we want to store
x, if we want to set the
value of x to something else?
So let's say this processor
wants to set x equal to 5.
So it's going to
write x equals 5
and store that result
in its own cache.
So that's all well and good.
Now what happens when the first
processor wants to load x?
Well, it seems that the value
of x is in its own cache,
so it's just going to
read the value of x there,
and it gets a value of 3.
So what's the problem there?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The path is stale.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah.
So the problem is that the value
of x in the first processor's
cache is stale, because
another processor updated it.
So now this value of x in
the first processor's cache
is invalid.
So that's the problem.
And one of the main challenges
of multicore hardware
is to try to solve this
problem of cache coherence--
making sure that the values in
different processors' caches
are consistent across updates.
So one basic protocol
for solving this problem
is known as the MSI protocol.
And in this protocol, each cache
line is labeled with a state.
So there are three
possible states--
M, S, and I. And this is done on
the granularity of cache lines.
Because it turns out that
storing this information
is relatively
expensive, so you don't
want to store it for
every memory location.
So they do it on a
per cache line basis.
Does anyone know what
the size of a cache line
is, on the machines
that we're using?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 64 bytes.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so it's 64 bytes.
And that's typically what you
see today on most Intel and AMD
machines.
There's some architectures that
have different cache lines,
like 128 bytes.
But for our class, the
machines that we're using
will have 64 byte cache lines.
It's important to remember
that so that when you're doing
back-of-the-envelope
calculations,
you can get accurate estimates.
So the three states in the
MSI protocol are M, S, and I.
So M stands for modified.
And when a cache block
is in the modified state,
that means no other caches
can contain this block
in the M or the S states.
The S state means that
the block is shared,
so other caches can also have
this block in shared state.
And then finally, I mean
the cache block is invalid.
So that's essentially the
same as the cache block
not being in the cache.
And to solve the problem
of cache coherency, when
one cache modifies
a location, it
has to inform all
the other caches
that their values are now stale,
because this cache modified
the value.
So it's going to invalidate
all of the other copies
of that cache line
in other caches
by changing their
state from S to I.
So let's see how this works.
So let's say that the second
processor wants to store y
equals 5.
So previously, a value of y was
17, and it was in shared state.
The cache line containing y
equals 17 was in shared state.
So now, when I do
y equals 5, I'm
going to set the second
processor's cache--
that cache line--
to modified state.
And then I'm going to
invalidate the cache
line in all of the other caches
that contain that cache line.
So now the first cache
and the fourth cache
each have a state of
I for y equals 17,
because that value is stale.
Is there any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If we already have to
tell the other things to switch
to invalid, why not just
tell them the value of y?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so there are actually
some protocols that do that.
So this is just the
most basic protocol.
So this protocol doesn't do it.
But there are some that
are used in practice
that actually do do that.
So it's a good point.
But I just want to present the
most basic protocol for now.
Sorry.
And then, when you
load a value, you
can first check whether your
cache line is in M or S state.
And if it is an M
or S state, then you
can just read that
value directly.
But if it's in the I state,
or if it's not there,
then you have to
fetch that block
from either another
processor's cache
or fetch it from main memory.
So it turns out that there are
many other protocols out there.
There's something known as
MESI, the messy protocol.
There's also MOESI and many
other different protocols.
And some of them
are proprietary.
And they all do
different things.
And it turns out that
all of these protocols
are quite complicated,
and it's very hard
to get these protocols right.
And in fact, one of the
most earliest successes
of formal verification was
improving some of these cache
[INAUDIBLE] protocols
to be correct.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: What happens if
two processors try to modify
one value at the same time
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so if two processors
try to modify the value, one
of them has to happen first.
So the hardware is going
to take care of that.
So the first one that
actually modifies
it will invalidate
all the other copies,
and then the second one
that modifies the value
will again invalidate
all of the other copies.
And when you do that--
when a lot of processors try
to modify the same value,
you get something known
as an invalidation storm.
So you have a bunch of
invalidation messages
going throughout the hardware.
And that can lead to a big
performance bottleneck.
Because each processor,
when it modifies its value,
it has to inform all
the other processors.
And if all the processors
are modifying the same value,
you get this sort of
quadratic behavior.
The hardware is still
going to guarantee
that one of their processors
is going to end up
writing the value there.
But you should be aware
of this performance issue
when you're writing
parallel code.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So all of
this protocol stuff
happens in hardware?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes, so this is
all implemented in hardware.
So if you take a computer
architecture class,
you'll learn much more about
these protocols and all
of their variants.
So for our purposes,
we don't actually
need to understand all the
details of the hardware.
We just need to understand
what it's doing at a high level
so we can understand when we
have a performance bottleneck
and why we have a
performance bottleneck.
So that's why I'm just
introducing the most
basic protocol here.
Any other questions?
So I talked a little bit about
the shared memory hardware.
Let's now look at some
concurrency platforms.
So these are the four platforms
that we'll be looking at today.
So first, what is a
concurrency platform?
Well, writing parallel
programs is very difficult.
It's very hard to get these
programs to be correct.
And if you want to
optimize their performance,
it becomes even harder.
So it's very painful
and error-prone.
And a concurrency platform
abstracts processor
cores and handles
synchronization
and communication protocols.
And it also performs
load balancing for you.
So it makes your
lives much easier.
And so today we're
going to talk about some
of these different
concurrency platforms.
So to illustrate these
concurrency platforms,
I'm going to do the
Fibonacci numbers example.
So does anybody not
know what Fibonacci is?
So good.
Everybody knows
what Fibonacci is.
So it's a sequence where
each number is the sum
of the previous two numbers.
And the recurrence is shown
in this brown box here.
The sequence is named after
Leonardo di Pisa, who was also
known as Fibonacci, which
is a contraction of Bonacci,
son of Bonaccio.
So that's where the name
Fibonacci came from.
And in Fibonacce's
1202 book, Liber Abaci,
he introduced the sequence--
the Fibonacci sequence--
to Western mathematics,
although it had been
previously known
to Indian mathematicians
for several centuries.
But this is what we call
the sequence nowadays--
Fibonacci numbers.
So here's a Fibonacci program.
Has anyone seen this
algorithm before?
A couple of people.
Probably more, but people
didn't raise their hands.
So it's a recursive program.
So it basically
implements the recurrence
from the previous slide.
So if n is less than
2, we just return n.
Otherwise, we compute
fib of n minus 1,
store that value in x, fib of n
minus 2, store that value in y,
and then return
the sum of x and y.
So I do want to
make a disclaimer
to the algorithms police
that this is actually
a very bad algorithm.
So this algorithm
takes exponential time,
and there's actually
much better ways
to compute the end
Fibonacci number.
There's a linear
time algorithm, which
just computes the Fibonacci
numbers from bottom up.
This algorithm here is actually
redoing a lot of the work,
because it's computing Fibonacci
numbers multiple times.
Whereas if you do a linear scan
from the smallest numbers up,
you only have to
compute each one once.
And there's actually an
even better algorithm
that takes logarithmic
time, and it's
based on squaring matrices.
So has anyone seen
that algorithm before?
So a couple of people.
So if you're interested
in learning more
about this algorithm,
I encourage
you to look at your favorite
textbook, Introduction
to Algorithms by Cormen,
Leiserson, Rivest, and Stein.
So even though this--
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
So even though this is
a pretty bad algorithm,
it's still a good
educational example,
because I can fit
it on one slide
and illustrate all the
concepts of parallelism
that we want to cover today.
So here's the execution
tree for fib of 4.
So we see that fib of 4 is going
to call fib of 3 and fib of 2.
Fib of 3 is going to call fib
of 2, fib of 1, and so on.
And you can see that
repeated computations here.
So fib of 2 is being
computed twice, and so on.
And if you have a
much larger tree--
say you ran this
on fib of 40-- then
you'll have many more
overlapping computations.
It turns out that the two
recursive calls can actually
be parallelized, because
they're completely independent
calculations.
So the key idea
for parallelization
is to simultaneously execute the
two recursive sub-calls to fib.
And in fact, you can
do this recursively.
So the two sub-calls
to fib of 3 can also
be executed in parallel, and
the two sub-calls of fib of 2
can also be executed
in parallel, and so on.
So you have all of
these calls that
can be executed in parallel.
So that's the key idea
for extracting parallelism
from this algorithm.
So let's now look
at how we can use
Pthreads to implement this
simple Fibonacci algorithm.
So Pthreads is a standard
API for threading,
and it's supported on
all Unix-based machines.
And if you're programming
using Microsoft products,
then the equivalent
is Win API threads.
And Pthreads is actually
standard in ANSI and IEEE,
so there's this number here
that specifies the standard.
But nowadays, we just
call it Pthreads.
And it's basically a
do-it-yourself concurrency
platform.
So it's like the
assembly language
of parallel programming.
It's built as a
library of functions
with special non-C semantics.
Because if you're just
writing code in C,
you can't really say
which parts of the code
should be executed in parallel.
So Pthreads provides
you a library
of functions that allow
you to specify concurrency
in your program.
And each thread implements an
abstraction of a processor,
and these threads
are then multiplexed
onto the actual
machine resources.
So the number of
threads that you create
doesn't necessarily have to
match the number of processors
you have on your machine.
So if you have more threads
than the number of processors
you have, then they'll
just be multiplexing.
So you can actually
run a Pthreads program
on a single core even though
you have multiple threads
in the program.
They would just be time-sharing.
All the threads communicate
through shared memory,
so they all have access to
the same view of the memory.
And the library functions
that Pthreads provides mask
the protocols involved in
interthread coordination,
so you don't have
to do it yourself.
Because it turns out that
this is quite difficult to
do correctly by hand.
So now I want to look at
the key Pthread functions.
So the first Pthread
is pthread_create.
And this takes four arguments.
So the first argument
is this pthread_t type.
This is basically going
to store an identifier
for the new thread
that pthread_create
will create so that
we can use that thread
in our computations.
pthread_attr_t-- this set
some thread attributes,
and for our purposes, we can
just set it to null and use
the default attributes.
The third argument
is this function
that's going to be executed
after we create the thread.
So we're going to need to
define this function that we
want the thread to execute.
And then finally, we have
this void *arg argument,
which stores the arguments
that are going to be passed
to the function that we're
going to be executing.
And then pthread_create also
returns an error status,
returns an integer specifying
whether the thread creation
was successful or not.
And then there's another
function called pthread_join.
pthread_join
basically says that we
want to block at
this part of our code
until this specified
thread finishes.
So it takes as
argument pthread_t.
So this thread identifier,
and these thread identifiers,
were created when we
called pthread_create.
It also has a second
argument, status,
which is going to
store the status
of the terminating thread.
And then pthread_join also
returns an error status.
So essentially what
this does is it
says to wait until this thread
finishes before we continue on
in our program.
So any questions so far?
So here's what the
implementation of Fibonacci
looks like using Pthreads.
So on the left, we see the
original program that we had,
the fib function there.
That's just the sequential code.
And then we have
all this other stuff
to enable it to run in parallel.
So first, we have this struct
on the left, thread_args.
This struct here is used
to store the arguments that
are passed to the function that
the thread is going to execute.
And then we have
this thread_func.
What that does is
it reads the input
argument from this
thread_args struct,
and then it sets that to i,
and then it calls fib of i.
And that gives you the output,
and then we store the result
into the output of the struct.
And then that also
just returns null.
And then over on
the right hand side,
we have the main function that
will actually call the fib
function on the left.
So we initialize a
whole bunch of variables
that we need to
execute these threads.
And then we first check
if n is less than 30.
If n is less than
30, it turns out
that it's actually not
worth creating threads
to execute this program
in parallel, because
of the overhead of
thread creation.
So if n is less than 30,
we'll just execute the program
sequentially.
And this idea is
known as coarsening.
So you saw a similar
example a couple of lectures
ago when we did
coarsening for sorting.
But this is in the context
of a parallel programming.
So here, because there
are some overheads
to running a
function in parallel,
if the input size
is small enough,
sometimes you want to just
execute it sequentially.
And then we're going to--
so let me just walk
through this code,
since I have an animation.
So the next thing
it's going to do
is it's going to marshal the
input argument to the thread
so it's going to store the
input argument n minus 1
in this args struct.
And then we're going
to call pthread_create
with a thread variable.
For thread_args, we're
just going to use null.
And then we're going
to pass the thread_func
that we defined on the left.
And then we're going to
pass the args structure.
And inside this args structure,
the input is set to n minus 1,
which we did on
the previous line.
And then pthread_create is
going to give a return value.
So if the Pthread
creation was successful,
then the status is going to
be null, and we can continue.
And when we
continue, we're going
to execute, now, fib of n minus
2 and store the result of that
into our result variable.
And this is done at the same
time that fib of n minus 1
is executing.
Because we created
this Pthread, and we
told it to call this
thread_func function
that we defined on the left.
So both fib of n minus
1 and fib of n minus 2
are executing in parallel now.
And then we have
this pthread_join,
which says we're going
to wait until the thread
that we've created finishes
before we move on, because we
need to know the result
of both of the sub-calls
before we can finish
this function.
And once that's done--
well, we first check the status
to see if it was successful.
And if so, then we add the
outputs of the argument's
struct to the result. So
args.output will store
the output of fib of n minus 1.
So that's the Pthreads code.
Any questions on how this works?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the thread function.
So it looks like you
passed a void pointer,
but then you cast it to
something else every time
you use that--
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so this is because
the pthread_create
function takes
as input a void star pointer.
Because it's actually
a generic function,
so it doesn't know
what the data type is.
It has to work for
all data types,
and that's why we need
to cast it to avoid star.
When we pass it to
pthread_create and then
inside the thread_func,
we actually
do know what type of pointer
that is, so then we cast it.
So does this code
seem very parallel?
So how many parallel
calls am I doing here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just one.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah, so I'm
only creating one thread.
So I'm executing two
things in parallel.
So if I ran this code
on four processors,
what's the maximum
speed-up I could get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: So the
maximum speed-up I can get
is just two, because I'm only
running two things in parallel.
So this doesn't
recursively create threads.
It only creates one
thread at the top level.
And if you wanted to make it
so that this code actually
recursively created
threads, it would actually
become much more complicated.
And that's one of the
disadvantages of implementing
this code in Pthreads.
So we'll look at other
solutions that will
make this task much easier.
So some of the
issues with Pthreads
are shown on this slide here.
So there's a high overhead
to creating a thread.
So creating a thread
typically takes over 10
to the 4th cycles.
And this leads to very
coarse-grained concurrency,
because your tasks have
to do a lot of work
in order to amortize the
costs of creating that thread.
There are something called
thread pulls, which can help.
And the idea here is to create
a whole bunch of threads
at the same time to amortize
the costs of thread creation.
And then when you need
a thread, you just
take one from the thread pull.
So the thread pull
contains threads that
are just waiting to do work.
There's also a scalability
issue with this code
that I showed on
the previous slide.
The Fibonacci code
gets, at most,
1.5x speed-up for two cores.
Why is it 1.5 here?
Does anyone know?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You have the asymmetry
in the size of the two calls.
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so it turns out
that the two calls that
I'm executing in parallel--
they're not doing the
same amount of work.
So one is computing
fib of n minus 1,
one is computing
fib of n minus 2.
And does anyone know what the
ratio between these two values
is?
Yeah, so it's the golden ratio.
It's about 1.6.
It turns out that if you
can get a speed-up of 1.6,
then that's great.
But there are some
overheads, so this code
will get about a 1.5 speed up.
And if you want to run this to
take advantage of more cores,
then you need to
rewrite this code,
and it becomes more complicated.
Third, there's the
issue of modularity.
So if you look at
this code here,
you see that the Fibonacci
logic is not nicely encapsulated
within one function.
We have that logic in the
fib function on the left,
but then we also have some
of the fib logic on the right
in our main function.
And this makes this
code not modular.
And if we want to build
programs on top of this,
it makes it very
hard to maintain,
if we want to just change
the logic of the Fibonacci
function a little
bit, because now we
have to change it
in multiple places
instead of just having
everything in one place.
So it's not a good idea to
write code that's not modular,
so please don't do
that in your projects.
And then finally,
the code becomes
complicated because you
have to actually move
these arguments around.
That's known as
argument marshaling.
And then you have to engage
in error-prone protocols
in order to do load balancing.
So if you recall here,
we have to actually
place the argument n
minus 1 into args.input
and we have to extract the
value out of args.output.
So that makes the
code very messy.
So why do I say
shades of 1958 here?
Does anyone know what
happened in 1958?
Who was around in 1958?
Just Charles?
So there was a first
something in 1958.
What was it?
So turns out in 1958, we
had the first compiler.
And this was the
Fortran compiler.
And before we had
Fortran compiler,
programmers were writing
things in assembly.
And when you write
things in assembly,
you have to do
argument marshaling,
because you have to place things
into the appropriate registers
before calling a function, and
also move things around when
you return from a function.
And the nice thing
about the first compiler
is that it actually did all
of this argument marshaling
for you.
So now you can just pass
arguments to a function,
and the compiler
will generate code
that will do the argument
marshaling for us.
So having you do
this in Pthreads
is similar to having to
write code in assembly,
because you have to
actually manually marshal
these arguments.
So hopefully, there are
better ways to do this.
And indeed, we'll look at some
other solutions that will make
it easier on the programmer.
Any questions before I continue?
So we looked at Pthreads.
Next, let's look at
Threading Building Blocks.
So Threading Building Blocks
is a library solution.
It was developed by Intel.
And it's implemented as a
C++ library that runs on top
of native threads.
So the underlying
implementation uses threads,
but the programmer
doesn't deal with threads.
Instead, the programmer
specifies tasks,
and these tasks are
automatically load-balanced
across the threads using
a work-stealing algorithm
inspired by research at MIT--
Charles Leiserson's research.
And the focus of Intel
TBB is on performance.
And as we'll see, the
code written using TBB
is simpler than
what you would have
to write if you used Pthreads.
So let's look at how we can
implement Fibonacci using TBB.
So in TBB, we have to
create these tasks.
So in the Fibonacci code, we
create this fib task class.
And inside the task, we have to
define this execute function.
So the execute function
is the function
that performs a computation
when we start the task.
And this is where we
define the Fibonacci logic.
This task also takes as input
these arguments parameter, n
and sum.
So n is the input here
and sum is the output.
And in TBB, we can easily
create a recursive program
that extracts more parallelism.
And here, what we're doing
is we're recursively creating
two child tasks, a and b.
That's the syntax for
creating the tasks.
And here, we can just pass
the arguments to FibTask
instead of marshaling
the arguments ourselves.
And then what we have
here is a set_ref_count.
And this basically is
the number of tasks
that we have to wait for plus
one, so plus one for ourselves.
And in this case, we
created two children tasks,
and we have ourselves,
so that's 2 plus 1.
And then after that, we start
task b using the spawn(b) call.
And then we do
spawn_and_wait_for_all
with a as the argument.
In this place, he says,
we're going to start task a,
and then also wait
for both a and b
to finish before we proceed.
So this
spawn_and_wait_for_all call
is going to look at the
ref count that we set above
and wait for that many tasks
to finish before it continues.
And after both and a
and b have completed,
then we can just
sum up the results
and store that into
the sum variable.
And here, these tasks
are created recursively.
So unlike the Pthreads
implementation
that was only creating one
thread at the top level,
here, we're actually recursively
creating more and more tasks.
So we can actually
get more parallelism
from this code and scale
to more processors.
We also need this main function
just to start up the program.
So what we do here is
we create a root task,
which just computes fib
of n, and then we call
spawn_root_and_wait(a).
So a is the task for the root.
And then it will just
run the root task.
So that's what Fibonacci
looks like in TBB.
So this is much simpler than
the Pthreads implementation.
And it also gets
better performance,
because we can extract
more parallelism
from the computation.
Any questions?
So TBB also has many other
features in addition to tasks.
So TBB provides many C++
templates to express common
patterns, and you can use these
templates on different data
types.
So they have a
parallel_for, which
is used to express
loop parallelism.
So you can loop over a bunch
of iterations in parallel.
They also have a parallel_reduce
for data aggregation.
For example, if you
want to sum together
a whole bunch of values, you
can use a parallel_reduce
to do that in parallel.
They also have
pipeline and filter.
That's used for
software pipelining.
TBB provides many concurrent
container classes,
which allow multiple threads
to safely access and update
the items in a
container concurrently.
So for example, they have hash
tables, trees, priority cues,
and so on.
And you can just use
these out of the box,
and they'll work in parallel.
You can do concurrent
updates and reads
to these data structures.
TBB also has a variety of mutual
exclusion library functions,
such as locks and
atomic operations.
So there are a lot
of features of TBB,
which is why it's one of
the more popular concurrency
platforms.
And because of all
of these features,
you don't have to implement many
of these things by yourself,
and still get pretty
good performance.
So TBB was a library solution
to the concurrency problem.
Now we're going to look at
two linguistic solutions--
OpenMP and Cilk.
So let's start with OpenMP.
So OpenMP is a specification
by an industry consortium.
And there are several compilers
available that support OpenMP,
both open source
and proprietary.
So nowadays, GCC,
ICC, and Clang all
support OpenMP, as
well as Visual Studio.
And OpenMP is-- it provides
linguistic extensions to C
and C++, as well as Fortran, in
the form of compiler pragmas.
So you use these
compiler pragmas
in your code to specify
which pieces of code
should run in parallel.
And OpenMP also runs on
top of native threads,
but the programmer isn't
exposed to these threads.
OpenMP supports
loop parallelism,
so you can do
parallel for loops.
They have task parallelism as
well as pipeline parallelism.
So let's look at how we can
implement Fibonacci in OpenMP.
So this is the entire code.
So I want you to compare this
to the Pthreads implementation
that we saw 10 minutes ago.
So this code is much
cleaner than the Pthreads
implementation, and it
also performs better.
So let's see how
this code works.
So we have these
compiler pragmas,
or compiler directives.
And the compiler pragma for
creating a parallel task
is omp task.
So we're going to create
an OpenMP task for fib
of n minus 1 as well
as fib of n minus 2.
There's also this
shared pragma, which
specifies that the two
variables in the arguments
are shared across
different threads.
So you also have to
specify whether variables
are private or shared.
And then the pragma
omp wait just
says we're going to wait
for the preceding task
to complete before we continue.
So here, it's going to
wait for fib of n minus 1
and fib of n minus 2
to finish before we
return the result,
which is what we want.
And then after that, we
just return x plus y.
So that's the entire code.
And OpenMP also provides
many other pragma directives,
in addition to task.
So we can use a parallel
for to do loop parallelism.
There's reduction.
There's also directives for
scheduling and data sharing.
So you can specify how
you want a particular loop
to be scheduled.
OpenMP has many different
scheduling policies.
They have static parallelism,
dynamic parallelism, and so on.
And then these scheduling
directives also
have different grain sizes.
The data sharing directives are
specifying whether variables
are private or shared.
OpenMP also supplies a variety
of synchronization constructs,
such as barriers, atomic
updates, mutual exclusion,
or mutex locks.
So OpenMP also
has many features,
and it's also one of the
more popular solutions
to writing parallel programs.
As you saw in the
previous example,
the code is much
simpler than if you
were to write something
using Pthreads or even TBB.
This is a much simpler solution.
Any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So with every
compiler directive,
does it spawn a new [INAUDIBLE]
on a different processor?
JULIAN SHUN: So this
code here is actually
independent of the
number of processors.
So there is actually
a scheduling algorithm
that will determine
how the tasks get
mapped to different processors.
So if you spawn a new task,
it doesn't necessarily put it
on a different processor.
And you can have more
tasks than the number
of processors available.
So there's a
scheduling algorithm
that will take care
of how these tasks get
mapped to different
processors, and that's
hidden from the programmer.
Although you can
use these scheduling
pragmas to give
hints to the compiler
how it should schedule it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is the
operating system [INAUDIBLE]
scheduling [INAUDIBLE]?
JULIAN SHUN: Underneath,
this is implemented
using Pthreads, which has to
make operating system calls to,
basically, directly talk
to the processor cores
and do multiplexing
and so forth.
So the operating system is
involved at a very low level.
So the last concurrency platform
that we'll be looking at today
is Cilk.
We're going to look at
Cilk Plus, actually.
And the Cilk part of Cilk Plus
is a small set of linguistic
extensions to C and C++ that
support fork-join parallelism.
So for example, the
Fibonacci example
uses fork-join
parallelism, so you
can use Cilk to implement that.
And the Plus part of Cilk Plus
supports vector parallelism,
which you had experience
working with in your homeworks.
So Cilk Plus was initially
developed by Cilk Arts,
which was an MIT spin-off.
And Cilk Arts was acquired
by Intel in July 2009.
And the Cilk Plus
implementation was
based on the award-winning Cilk
multi-threaded language that
was developed two decades
ago here at MIT by Charles
Leiserson's research group.
And it features a
provably efficient
work-stealing scheduler.
So this scheduler is
provably efficient.
You can actually prove
theoretical bounds on it.
And this allows you to implement
theoretically efficient
algorithms, which we'll talk
more about in another lecture--
algorithm design.
But it provides a
provably efficient
work-stealing scheduler.
And Charles Leiserson
has a very famous paper
that has a proof of that
this scheduler is optimal.
So if you're interested
in reading about this,
you can talk to us offline.
Cilk Plus also provides
a hyperobject library
for parallelizing code
with global variables.
And you'll have a chance to
play around with hyperobjects
in homework 4.
The Cilk Plus
ecosystem also includes
useful programming tools,
such as the Cilk Screen Race
Detector.
So this allows you to
detect determinacy races
in your program to help you
isolate bugs and performance
bottlenecks.
It also has a scalability
analyzer called Cilk View.
And Cilk View will basically
analyze the amount of work
that your program
is doing, as well as
the maximum amount
of parallelism
that your code could possibly
extract from the hardware.
So that's Intel Cilk Plus.
But it turns out that
we're not actually
going to be using Intel
Cilk Plus in this class.
We're going to be using
a better compiler.
And this compiler is
based on Tapir/LLVM.
And it supports the Cilk
subset of Cilk Plus.
And Tapir/LLVM was actually
recently developed at MIT
by T. B. Schardl, who gave
a lecture last week, William
Moses, who's a grad student
working with Charles,
as well as Charles Leiserson.
So talking a lot about
Charles's work today.
And Tapir/LLVM
generally produces
better code, relative
to its base compiler,
than all other implementations
of Cilk out there.
So it's the best Cilk compiler
that's available today.
And they actually
wrote a very nice paper
on this last year, Charles
Leiserson and his group.
And that paper received
the Best Paper Award
at the annual Symposium on
Principles and Practices
of Parallel
Programming, or PPoPP.
So you should look at
that paper as well.
So right now, Tapir/LLVM uses
the Intel Cilk Plus runtime
system, but I believe Charles's
group has plans to implement
a better runtime system.
And Tapir/LLVM also supports
more general features
than existing Cilk compilers.
So in addition to
spawning functions,
you can also spawn code
blocks that are not
separate functions,
and this makes
writing programs more flexible.
You don't have to actually
create a separate function
if you want to execute a
code block in parallel.
Any questions?
So this is the Cilk
code for Fibonacci.
So it's also pretty simple.
It looks very similar to
the sequential program,
except we have these
cilk_spawn and cilk_synv
statements in the code.
So what do these statements do?
So cilk_spawn says that the
named child function, which
is the function that is
right after this cilk_spawn
statement, may execute in
parallel with the parent
caller.
The parent caller
is the function
that is calling cilk_spawn.
So this says that
fib of n minus 1
can execute in parallel with
the function that called it.
And then this function is then
going to call fib of n minus 2.
And fib of n minus 2
and fib of n minus 1
now can be executing
in parallel.
And then cilk_sync says that
control cannot pass this point
until all of the spawn
children have returned.
So this is going to wait
for fib of n minus 1
to return before we go
to the return statement
where we add up x and y.
So one important
thing to note is
that the Cilk keywords
grant permission
for parallel execution, but they
don't actually force or command
parallel execution.
So even though I
said cilk_spawn here,
the runtime system
doesn't necessarily
have to run fib of n minus 1 in
parallel with fib of n minus 2.
I'm just saying that I could run
these two things in parallel,
and it's up to
the runtime system
to decide whether or not to
run these things in parallel,
based on its scheduling policy.
So let's look at
another example of Cilk.
loop parallelism.
So here we want to do
a matrix transpose,
and we want to do this in-place.
So the idea here is we
want to basically swap
the elements below the
diagonal to its mirror
image above the diagonal.
And here's some code to do this.
So we have a cilk_for.
So this is basically
a parallel for loop.
It goes from i equals
1 to n minus 1.
And then the inner for loop
goes from j equals 0 up
to i minus 1.
And then we just swap
a of i j with a of j i,
using these three statements
inside the body of the
for loop.
So to execute a for
loop in parallel,
you just have to add cilk
underscore to the for keyword.
And that's as simple as it gets.
So this code is actually
going to run in parallel
and get pretty good speed-up
for this particular problem.
And internally,
Cilk for loops are
transformed into nested
cilk_spawn and cilk_sync calls.
So the compiler is going
to get rid of the cilk_for
and change it into
cilk_spawn and cilk_sync.
So it's going to recursively
divide the iteration
space into half, and then it's
going to spawn off one half
and then execute the other
half in parallel with that,
and then recursively do
that until the iteration
range becomes small
enough, at which point
it doesn't make sense to
execute it in parallel anymore,
so we just execute that
range sequentially.
So that's loop
parallelism in Cilk.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How does it know
[INAUDIBLE] something weird,
can it still do that?
JULIAN SHUN: Yeah,
so the compiler
can actually figure out
what the iteration space is.
So you don't necessarily
have to be incrementing by 1.
You can do something else.
You just have to guarantee
that all of the iterations
are independent.
So if you have a
determinacy race
across the different iterations
of your cilk_for loop,
then your result might not
necessarily be correct.
So you have to make sure that
the iterations are, indeed,
independent.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
nest cilk_fors?
JULIAN SHUN: Yes, so
you can nest cilk_fors.
But it turns out that,
for this example,
usually, you already
have enough parallelism
in the outer loop for
large enough values of n,
so it doesn't make sense to
put a cilk_for loop inside,
because using a cilk_for loop
adds some additional overheads.
But you can actually do
nested cilk_for loops.
And in some cases,
it does make sense,
especially if there's
not enough parallelism
in the outermost for loop.
So good question.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What does
the assembly code
look like for the parallel code?
JULIAN SHUN: So it has a bunch
of calls to the Cilk runtime
system.
I don't know all the
details, because I haven't
looked at this recently.
But I think you can
actually generate
the assembly code using a
flag in the Clang compiler.
So that's a good exercise.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
you probably want
to look at the LLVM IR,
rather than the assembly,
to begin with, to
understand what's going on.
It has three
instructions that are not
in the standard LLVM, which were
added to support parallelism.
Those things, when it's
lowered into assembly,
each of those
instructions becomes
a bunch of assembly
language instructions.
So you don't want to mess with
looking at it in the assembler
until you see what it looks
like in the LLVM first.
JULIAN SHUN: So good question.
Any other questions
about this code here?
OK, so let's look
at another example.
So let's say we
had this for loop
where, on each
iteration i, we're
just incrementing a
variable sum by i.
So this is essentially
going to compute
the summation of everything
from i equals 0 up to n minus 1,
and then print out the result.
So one straightforward way to
try to parallelize this code
is to just change
the for to cilk_for.
So does this code work?
Who thinks that this
code doesn't work?
Or doesn't compute
the correct result?
So about half of you.
And who thinks this
code does work?
So a couple people.
And I guess the rest of
the people don't care.
So it turns out that it's not
actually necessarily going
to give you the right answer.
Because the cilk_for
loop says you
can execute these
iterations in parallel,
but they're all updating the
same shared variable sum here.
So you have what's called
a determinacy race, where
multiple processors can be
writing to the same memory
location.
We'll talk much more
about determinacy races
in the next lecture.
But for this example,
it's not necessarily
going to work if you run it
on more than one processor.
And Cilk actually has a
nice way to deal with this.
So in Cilk, we have
something known as a reducer.
This is one example
of a hyperobject,
which I mentioned earlier.
And with a reducer,
what you have to do
is, instead of declaring
the sum variable just
has an unsigned long
data type, what you do
is you use this macro called
CILK_C_REDUCER_OPADD, which
specifies we want to create
a reducer with the addition
function.
Then we have the
variable name sum,
the data type unsigned long,
and then the initial value 0.
And then we have a macro
to register this reducer,
so a CILK_C_REGISTER_REDUCER.
And then now, inside
this cilk_for loop,
we can increment the sum,
or REDUCER_VIEW, of sum,
which is another macro, by i.
And you can actually
execute this in parallel,
and it will give
you the same answer
that you would get if you
ran this sequentially.
So the reducer will take care of
this determinacy race for you.
And at the end, when you
print out this result,
you'll see that the sum is equal
to the sum that you expect.
And then after you
finish using the reducer,
you use this other macro called
CILK_C_UNREGISTER_REDUCER(sum)
that tells the system that
you're done using this reducer.
So this is one way to
deal with this problem
when you want to do a reduction.
And it turns out that there
are many other interesting
reduction operators that
you might want to use.
And in general, you can
create reduces for monoids.
And monoids are
algebraic structures
that have an associative
binary operation as well
as an identity element.
So the addition
operator is a monoid,
because it's
associative, it's binary,
and the identity element is 0.
Cilk also has several
other predefined reducers,
including multiplication, min,
max, and, or, xor, et cetera.
So these are all monoids.
And you can also define
your own reducer.
So in fact, in
the next homework,
you'll have the opportunity
to play around with reducers
and write a reducer for lists.
So that's reducers.
Another nice thing about
Cilk is that there's always
a valid serial interpretation
of the program.
So the serial elision
of a Cilk program
is always a legal
interpretation.
And for the Cilk source
code on the left,
the serial elision
is basically the code
you get if you get
rid of the cilk_spawn
and cilk_sync statements.
And this looks just like
the sequential code.
And remember that the Cilk
keywords grant permission
for parallel execution,
but they don't necessarily
command parallel execution.
So if you ran this Cilk
code using a single core,
it wouldn't actually create
these parallel tasks,
and you would get
the same answer
as the sequential program.
And this is-- in the
serial edition-- is also
a correct interpretation.
So unlike other solutions,
such as TBB and Pthreads,
it's actually difficult,
in those environments,
to get a program that does what
the sequential program does.
Because they're actually
doing a lot of additional work
to set up these parallel calls
and create these argument
structures and other
scheduling constructs.
Whereas in Cilk,
it's very easy just
to get this serial elision.
You just define cilk_spawn
and cilk_sync to be null.
You also define
cilk_for to be for.
And then this gives you a
valid sequential program.
So when you're
debugging code, and you
might first want to check if the
sequential elision of your Cilk
program is correct,
and you can easily
do that by using these macros.
Or actually, there's
actually a compiler flag
that will do that for you
and give you the equivalent C
program.
So this is a nice way
to debug, because you
don't have to start with
the parallel program.
You can first check if this
serial program is correct
before you go on to debug
the parallel program.
Questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So does cilk_for--
does each iteration of
the cilk_for its own task
that the scheduler decides if
it wants to execute in parallel,
or if it executes in parallel,
do all of the iterations
execute in parallel?
JULIAN SHUN: So it turns
out that by default,
it groups a bunch of iterations
together into a single task,
because it doesn't make
sense to break it down
into such small chunks, due to
the overheads of parallelism.
But there's actually
a setting you
can do to change the grain
size of the for loop.
So you could actually make
it so that each iteration
is its own task.
And then, as you
the scheduler will
decide how to map
these different task
onto different
processors, or even
if it wants to execute any
of these tasks in parallel.
So good question.
So the idea in Cilk is
to allow the programmer
to express logical
parallelism in an application.
So the programmer
just has to identify
which pieces of the code
could be executed in parallel,
but doesn't necessarily have to
determine which pieces of code
should be executed in parallel.
And then Cilk has
a runtime scheduler
that will automatically
map the executing
program onto the available
processor cores' runtime.
And it does this
dynamically using
a work-stealing
scheduling algorithm.
And the work-stealing
scheduler is
used to balance the
tasks evenly across
the different processors.
And we'll talk more about
the work-stealing scheduler
in a future lecture.
But I want to emphasize that
unlike the other concurrency
platforms that we
looked at today,
Cilk's work-stealing scheduling
algorithm is theoretically
efficient, whereas the OpenMP
and TBB schedulers are not
theoretically efficient.
So this is a nice property,
because it will guarantee you
that the algorithms you
write on top of Cilk
will also be
theoretically efficient.
So here's a high-level
illustration
of the Cilk ecosystem.
It's a very simplified
view, but I did this
to fit it on a single slide.
So what you do is you
take the Cilk source code,
you pass it to your
favorite Cilk compiler--
the Tapir/LLVM
compiler-- and this
gives you a binary that you
can run on multiple processors.
And then you pass a program
input to the binary,
you run it on however
many processors you have,
and then this allows you
to benchmark the parallel
performance of your program.
You can also do serial testing.
And to do this, you just obtain
a serial elision of the Cilk
program, and you pass it to
an ordinary C or C++ compiler.
It generates a binary that can
only run on a single processor,
and you run your suite of
serial regression tests
on this single threaded binary.
And this will allow you to
benchmark the performance
of your serial code and
also debug any issues
that might have arised
when you were running
this program sequentially.
Another way to do this
is you can actually just
compile the original
Cilk code but run it
on a single processor.
So there's a command
line argument
that tells the runtime system
how many processors you
want to use.
And if you set that
parameter to 1,
then it will only use
a single processor.
And this allows you to benchmark
the single threaded performance
of your code as well.
And the parallel program
executing on a single core
should behave
exactly the same way
as the execution of
this serial elision.
So that's one of the
advantages of using Cilk.
And because you can easily do
serial testing using the Cilk
platform, this allows
you to separate out
the serial correctness from
the parallel correctness.
As I said earlier, you can first
debug the serial correctness,
as well as any performance
issues, before moving on
to the parallel version.
And another point
I want to make is
that because Cilk actually
uses the serial program
inside its task, it's
actually good to optimize
the serial program
even when you're
writing a parallel
program, because optimizing
the serial program
for performance
will also translate to
better parallel performance.
Another nice feature
of Cilk is that it
has this tool called
Cilksan, which
stands for Cilk Sanitizer.
And Cilksan will detect
any determinacy races
that you have in your code,
which will significantly
help you with debugging
the correctness
as well as the
performance of your code.
So if you compile the Cilk
code using the Cilksan flag,
it will generate an instrumented
binary that, when you run,
it will find and localize
all the determinacy races
in your program.
So it will tell you where
the determinacy races occur,
so that you can go inspect
that part of your code
and fix it if necessary.
So this is a very useful
tool for benchmarking
your parallel programs.
Cilk also has another nice
tool called Cilkscale.
Cilkscale is a
performance analyzer.
It will analyze how
much parallelism
is available in your program
as well as the total amount
of work that it's doing.
So again, you pass a
flag to the compiler that
will turn on Cilkscale,
and it will generate
a binary that is instrumented.
And then when you
run this code, it
will give you a
scalability report.
So you'll find these
tools very useful when
you're doing the next project.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about these two tools
in the next lecture.
And as I said, Cilkscale will
analyze how well your program
will scale to larger machines.
So it will basically tell
you the maximum number
of processors that your code
could possibly take advantage
of.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean when you say runtime?
JULIAN SHUN: So I mean the
scheduler-- the Cilk runtime
scheduler that's scheduling
the different tasks when
you're running the program.
AUDIENCE: So that's
included in the binary.
JULIAN SHUN: So it's
linked from the binary.
It's not stored
in the same place.
It's linked.
Other questions?
So let me summarize
what we looked at today.
So first, we saw that
most processors today
have multiple cores.
And probably all of your laptops
have more than one core on it.
Who has a laptop that
only has one core?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN SHUN: When
did you buy it?
Probably a long time ago.
So nowadays, obtaining high
performance on your machines
requires you to write
parallel programs.
But parallel programming
can be very hard,
especially if you have
the program directly
on the processor cores and
interact with the operating
system yourself.
So Cilk is very nice, because
it abstracts the processor cores
from the programmer, it
handles synchronization
and communication protocols,
and it also performs
provably good load-balancing.
And in the next project,
you'll have a chance
to play around with Cilk.
You'll be implementing your
own parallel screensaver,
so that's a very
fun project to do.
And possibly, in one
of the future lectures,
we'll post some of
the nicest screensaver
that students developed
for everyone to see.
OK, so that's all.